daddy had some interesting interesting
time yesterday i went to san diego-la
jolla one of your favorite with my
favorite place in the world yeah well I
had a move there and I know I don't I
understand I understand I I personally
think you might get bored there at the
end of the day Texas or La Jolla La
Jolla no papa
you're my chill I know and I went to my
boy Tony's house and Encinitas it's
beautiful you can get some houses and
some views so cheap it's not cheap
though is it
no but goddamn we're here and the
weather is goddamn nice and I will see
the best it's the best and then they got
the rock something coffee up there oh
yeah now I had to go to health nucleolus
craig venter the venture capitalist
futurist slash longevity guru i went
there to get a very expensive checkup
you didn't yeah hey did you floor no I
didn't but it smells like hey it's your
egg that hard egg okay but then you're
talking like wasn't far didn't I say I
walk through the bathroom I go it smells
like and he goes no eat I'm like oh well
Brian farted ideas Moe's like an old man
smells like sulfur it was it's your egg
Hassan Alton cattail I was like it
smells like ass and she's like what why
is this not really another eggs have so
far yeah smells like when the protesters
[ __ ] is in my fitting they've been
protesting all day in the Sun yeah and
their [ __ ] just run it's a rock
screaming screaming like this yeah and
their ass is it my nose like it's okay
I'm sorry I accused you of that that's
all right that's all right okay so you
got the work done so I went to health
nucleolus now they do a full body MRI at
the bottom there's an hour and a half
you know in a cone
amount that's a aren't half in a tunnel
you're I'm claustrophobic
well so I'm not so it's not a problem
but the problem is it's an hour and a
half where you just have to sit there
and the sound is this gang gang gang
Gujrat stay very still listen your pot a
podcast with music not you forgot
doesn't you can't and I'll tell you why
they put gave me music it's too loud
it's too loud you can't hear anything
and you can't have headphones they have
to be their headphones why cuz it's
magnets or can't have any metal so
there's that and
here's what was disconcerting they take
13,000 images of your head your whole
body and they're looking for tumors they
find any tumors you didn't do the
results but I didn't get the results
back but I don't like that they're
looking that carefully you wanna hire
your age like you never want to just pop
up well yeah I mean it's true that if I
do that you like it'd be nice to know
that beforehand it'd be nice my god look
you guys I touch that time the dye for
the for the UFC I forget I think it's
fight in California used to have real
strict real strict like you guys know
sir regulations
I always keep this to myself yeah I
should be the strict Street to get a cat
scan an MRI everything to fight this
cornea and they do it and he become he's
I go I need to talk you men coming he's
my friend my friend work for the Broncos
I'm great guy genius
straight up genius went to Harvard when
he's like 14 yeah dr. Chad and so I'm
like he's a hey can you stop by the
office like you know if anyone just
[ __ ] about you know supple as I
don't know Broncos oh my so we did
you're in he was like flipping through
like source magazines like oh yeah we
did it
everything's good get this tumor in the
back but it's uh yeah man it's not a big
deal I'm like what do you say think it's
tumor but I'm pretty sure you're born
with it but we should prank even I on it
gets in the back it's like oh I thought
it's back there but we should just keep
an eye on it because it grows then
you're gonna have to surgeon and take
your brain like you said you'll die if
you say they can't really take it out
well yeah he's like it's in it's in a
spot where we couldn't operate cuz they
do irreplaceable damage we couldn't
function so that was fun and then
Brennan I got my car and I could not
stop crying
can i sir I didn't tell anyway I don't
tell anybody
you have to sign like special waivers to
California Commission being like it's a
benign tumor it hasn't grown which he
doesn't know she took my he took the MRI
when I heard what that scan when I was
whatever 24 25 we have no idea what it
looks guy like that can tell if it's a
glioblastoma though usually usually oh
why cause he invented the brain surgery
what you do with the robotic arms that's
his that's his thing that he came up he
went to hardware's 14 dude yeah so I
believe them oh yeah oh you'd be dead by
now sir
see you know oh dude oh my friend my
friends my friends sister just had brain
surgery and she had she had one a new
seizure and they were like oh you got a
tumor in your brain but it was a benign
tumor and then they had to go through
her eyelid they went through under her
eye and took that [ __ ] thing out
she'll be fine
but she said the pain she goes I'm the
pain I am I literally can't take this
headache she was on morphine the pain
for after the surgery or yes mr. the
nurse has been through all this
she goes why is it hurting I've never
felt this kind of pain before in my head
and the nurse goes well have you ever
had brain surgery before Jim point you
know what I mean he denied someone drill
in your skull yeah through the front the
pain was at a nine now it's at a four so
it's getting better and I do parkour and
I was standing there yeah I ger does it
I went to get my I get went to get a
consultation on my lids because I had to
have a consultation on my lids sure now
a couple things you guys need to know
that you don't know
I'm getting my lids done we house he
said I would do the lower hell yeah I
would do the lower it'll make a
difference nobody's gonna be able to
tell you don't talk about on your
podcast Thomas you yeah you're gonna
look like the Chuck E Cheese like I'm
always listening
now hold on Brendan I asked him that he
said you're not gonna notice really well
it's a little see you look great because
we're gonna look like this no I'm not
your brow lifts and not doing brows I'm
just doing this as you and drew brees
agent column told that his [ __ ] didn't
go over well you take this yep
no listen it's gonna be fine and you
look like that you're very good a the
best yeah I would say that as a gift I'm
not gonna look like that
come on like guys watch this stuff you
notice watch this I go I know but I my
mother told me if you do that it gets
hollow cuz the fat comes out and he goes
oh no we're gonna shoot some fat in from
you heard from your tummy why does that
I don't get it done
I go liposuction I don't want to do that
is it permanent knee goes yeah he goes
hey oh my god I got a great story for
you guys it's fine you can take fat out
I don't know if I can tell this for it
no [ __ ] your story they can suck fat out
and it stays gone forever they can do
anything how about this maybe I need to
you
how about this my man was I hope I can
tell the story a plastic surgeon a
plastic surgeon
was doing a facelift on a man now fat
plastic surgeons on men take a long time
for whatever reason much longer than
women and there
the office was on the second floor mmm
in Beverly Hills okay now that's Beverly
Hills brother mm-hmm the ludus came
through oh no it was a 14-hour operation
was this the movie face off
what do you ready for this I don't know
that's how long it takes ugly dude a lot
of work either way yeah he's gonna look
fantastic apparently doubt it the
looters came through the pharmacies
downstairs they heard the wood the
windows of the pharmacy break oh they
took all the they heard all the looters
they took all the but they were setting
fires Bubba
oh my so you know Waco he's in the
middle of [ __ ] you can't wake him up
his face is face is half up it's a movie
face off you can't wait linkless caged
in there they're they're operating on
him and they can hear with the ended up
going bang bang bang and they're on the
phones please go look they're setting
fires to the building right there
if they set a fire here we're dead and
also this guy's dead he's dead you can't
do this sure and they were and they
broke over us and it was so [ __ ]
terrifying and they're like they were
praying and they the blue does thank God
I guess raided the pharmacy and then
moved on and he finished it up and it
was like what the [ __ ] does the guy wake
up and like we have good news and bad
news good news is God your face is done
your face says you mean a lot of pains
we have no painkillers no faint pink oh
the looters took all of them and that's
probably we do have some tylenol for
that's probably what happened and good
luck but yeah I'm getting my list on the
16th I'm gonna need the table but no
puppet you're coming in here I will I'm
gonna be very populist you know I'm
gonna come home I can't wait I'm gonna
come in I'll be countdown I'll be super
puffy and then for ten days I can't do
any exercise because I can't raise my
blood pressure so no surf and turf and I
got to do the podcast and y'all calm and
then 10 days so 16th on the 25th I'm on
stage in San Antonio is it the 25th I
think so
is that when I'm in smoking I'd love to
come Santoni I do that's my scene right
now and I'm it I want to go to submit
the
err called me as a kid that cool Frank
comes through I want yeah cool
I don't know I know it's my city I
didn't know that yes my city
really mmm congratulations thank you
that relations right now yeah yeah yeah
yeah watch your tongue Oh what's gonna
happen what are you gonna do use some of
that boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]